l'album comme chaque lundi cette fois le
quart zoo a rencontré le dessinateur de
bd marcel gotlib sa passion musicale
peut surprendre quand on connaît son
trait et son texte
c'est un classique moderne qu'il
apprécie je ne vous en dis pas plus
écoutez plutôt sa réponse j'avais
plusieurs puisque j'ai des goûts
extrêmement éclectique
là en ce moment il se trouve que c'est
en train d'écouter on dessine en jonque
en écouter un morceau d'erik satie qui
s'appelle parade
le cas particulier de satie je
qualifierais sa de musique mélancolique
ou rigolotes
c'est à dire que déjà ne serait-ce que
les filtres les choses comme ça et puis
dans la musique de sacy proprement dit
il ya quelque chose qui me semble
correspondre à cette définition
voilà la musique plus
c'est un plaisir en tant que tel si elle
a une influence sur mon travail c'est
après coup après avoir été arrêtés ont
géré par mois
ce qu'on a fait il ya un monde de
musique une musique classique elle est
très je vous estimez ou bien alors les
jeunes de maintenant ne s'y intéresse
pas beaucoup je peux me tromper
ton est ce que vous feriez pour les
intéresser à cette île c'est pas mon
boulot ce jeu si vous deviez le faire
mais je leur dirai il faut l'écouter